Welcome back everyone this will be my doctor
strange two trailer breakdown there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs it's the second spider-man
no way home post-credits scene after the actual
credits there's so many things that we have to
talk about here so many easter eggs so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i'm doing a giveaway for imax
tickets for spider-man no way home all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
your favorite moment from this doctor strange 2
trailer in the comments careful for spoilers for
spider-man no way home if you haven't seen the
movie yet we have to talk about what happened
during that in the ending and how that sets
up what's happening during doctor strange 2
but the trailer picks up right after the end
of spider-man no way home after that time jump
where he creates his new spider-man suit that
looks like the classic comic book suit and it's
christmas time like a couple months have gone
by but the trailer actually starts with a couple
dialogue scenes from spider-man no way home
mixed with some deleted scenes from the movie
doctor strange telling spider-man the multiverse
is a concept about which we know frighteningly
little the deleted scene that some of you may
have recognized is actually from the spider-man
no way home trailer of wong yelling at doctor
strange in the entrance hall saying don't cast
that spell when spider-man asks him about it
strange don't cast that spell it's too dangerous
fine i won't if you watch the movie in theaters
that scene is not in the theatrical cut he says
something different he just says okay fine keep
me out of this and then goes to camartage the
first actual new scene of doctor strange 2 is
of doctor strange's broken watch that was given
to him by christine in the first doctor strange
movie like he puts it on at the end of that film
you can see his face reflected in the broken glass
but the fact that they open on a broken watch is
also meant to be a metaphor about the plot about
how reality is breaking just in general it also
kind of reminds you of kang because it's a watch
for keeping time and kang is a time travel villain
some of you also probably sense the kang vibes
that are coming off some of these scenes it seems
very similar to what we saw play out during
the loki series with kang and his variants
because there are a couple different versions
of doctor strange in this and they're trying to
make you think that doctor strange himself is the
main villain of the film or one of his variants
is one of the main villains like doctor strange
supreme that they reveal at the end of the trailer
if you think i'm bad wait till you meet my
variants but make it doctor strange kang himself
isn't supposed to be the main villain of a big
marvel movie till ant-man 3 but the concept of
reality also includes the timeline the multiverse
so there'd have to be some association with the
kang multiverse war during this too at least way
off in the distance then as doctor strange comes
rushing up the stairs in a version of the sanctum
that looks like it's been combined with a beach
like something about reality has warped and it's
like somebody sanctum it might not be his it
might be a sanctum from another universe sinking
into this beach you hear baron mordo say your
desecration of reality will not go unpunished then
you see him in what seems like a version of new
york city just rushing through these gates looking
up into the sky as reality like the earth is just
kind of crashing in on itself there's also this
melting effect like everything is melting up into
the sky it looks very similar to what happened to
the earth doctor strange supreme came from in the
what if series and during his episode he basically
destroyed his entire universe trying to undo an
absolute point in time but he says it was the only
way and it sounds like that's a reference to him
fixing the memory spell that started to break
reality during spider-man away home with those
giant purple tears in reality so they kind of want
you to think that what he did during spider-man no
way home with the spell like it was kind of his
fault also kind of spider-man's fault that the
spell broke because he agreed to perform it in
the first place when he probably shouldn't have
it sounds like what's happening here with reality
breaking is a consequence of what they did but
also a consequence of what these other versions of
doctor strange from different universes are doing
like doctor strange supreme who at the end of the
trailer has a line of dialogue saying things got
kind of out of hand making you think of that
what if doctor strange episode then we see him
outside in the streets of new york city with
reality warping all around him people in the
background just running in tear it's very similar
to the avengers infinity war scene when the black
order attacks them in the street and it seems like
doctor strange in america chavez are getting ready
to fight gargantos and he's that big creature that
looks like schumachur the giant eyeball with all
the tentacles he creates that magical buzz saw
to cut the bus in half when gargantos throws it
at them and here's the thing because they're using
gargantos like this i think it's less likely that
schumachorth is actually the main villain and
instead of him being the main villain they're
trying to say that variants of doctor strange or
doctor strange supreme is the main villain or at
least they want you to think that marvel trailers
are always very misleading but then we see a bunch
of flashes starting with scarlet witch using her
chaos magic we see christine palmer at a wedding
and she's not getting married to doctor strange
like she's walking quickly past him down the aisle
doctor strange did make a reference about his sort
of personal relationships during spider-man their
way home it was kind of a joke because when
he starts fighting spider-man he says this
is why i never wanted to have kids just because
there's such a pain in the butt such a handful but
the idea is that he kind of had to sacrifice his
personal relationship to become the most powerful
sorcerer in the universe even though they did have
the big joke about wong being the actual sorcerer
supreme but the idea is that doctor strange is
more powerful but as they imply through all the
trailer footage in the events of spider-man no
way home he gets himself into as many problems as
spider-man does like the more powerful you are the
more reckless you are the more damage you cause so
spider-man no way home was a local spider-man
ruins everything kind of situation and they're
giving us the exact same vibe with the doctor
strange two trailer local wizard ruins everything
there are so many wizard jokes during spider-man
their way home a wizard's dungeon doctor magic
even the goatee template that mj finds in the
undercroft like doctor strange used using a goatee
template to make a better looking goatee we see
our first actual scene of america chavez in her
comic book costume also known as miss america
but i think they'll probably just call her by
her first name in the movie like everyone calls
wanda wanda they don't call her scarlet witch
america chavez was born outside of the main mcu
reality in a pocket dimension her big ability is
punching holes through other dimensions other
realities she can even open portals to higher
planes of existence without spell casting so
a lot of times you'll see her showing up in
multiverse and very cosmic stories in the comics
they also might wind up using her in a big young
avengers team up in the mcu either like a disney
plus series or a young avengers movie however
they want to accomplish that because it seems like
they're setting that up wong looking like he gets
all strung up by someone that's captured him i bet
he's regretting being sorcerer supreme right now
maybe it's baron mordo because you do see baron
mordo fighting the main mcu doctor strange later
then there's this really cool scene of defender
strange that you guys probably spotted spinning
through this multiple dimensions it's like the
scene of the first doctor strange movie when he
went through all the different universes and
dimensions defender strange is just another
version of doctor strange from the multiverse
based on the defenders comic book version he's
got a ponytail his costume looks like this the red
and black one so now we know there are at least
three different versions of doctor strange from
the multiverse in the movie there might be more
that we just don't see during the trailer then
we finally get to see the scene of doctor strange
going to visit wanda after the events of the
wandavision post credit scene if i'm not mistaken
this is supposed to be the same basic area where
we last saw her but it looks like she's either
moved to a new house or she's created one with her
magic it looks like she's just been chilling out
gardening between her study sessions with the dark
hole just trying to process her grief over losing
vision again her children billy and tommy they
answer some of your questions from wandavision in
this scene too like wanda lets him know that she
expected him to show up and hold her accountable
for what happened with the hex and what she did in
west view but he's like no i don't care about that
we're just here because of what's happening
with reality breaking down what do you know
about the multiverse it sounds like she knows a
little bit like she's been studying the dark hold
and the dark hole probably has information about
other realities then there's a separate scene of
doctor strange in america chavez opening a door
to what seems like this nexus point surrounding
some huge power source like this might be one of
the macguffins of the movie some magical artifact
that seems super important to the plot the visual
language here too with the way everything is kind
of broken apart kind of reminds you of the end of
the first doctor strange movie when things started
to get really crazy inside the mirror dimension
it looks kind of like the ruins of an ancient
temple that have just broken apart because reality
is broken then we have that scene of baron mordo
apologizing to doctor strange telling him he's
sorry but he is the greatest threat to reality
as they make the big strange supreme reveal in
the way they're playing this scene here of him
meeting the doctor strange supreme version seems
very much like a he who remains king kind of scene
from loki where he explained all of his dangerous
variants like you think i'm bad wait till you
meet my variants in baron mordo is speaking more
in metaphors like you and your variants doctor
strange are the greatest threat to the multiverse
there's a dark cloud that comes over kamar taj
with everyone looking at it ominously scarlet
witch inside a circle levitating as it seems like
she's trying to cast a spell using her chaos magic
she's wearing her new costume from wandavision and
even though we don't see the dark hold here they
probably have it somewhere during the movie and
then we see doctor strange manipulating a bunch
of objects weaving a spell but the objects are
laced with chaos magic so either he's trying to
use chaos magic himself or he has scarlet witch
helping him do this then there's a fight scene
of him with america chavez trying to defend her
creating these magical snake-like dragons to
attack someone and obviously the really big scene
here is of him going to talk to doctor strange
supreme like he's kind of afraid he's not really
sure what's going on here like loki reacting to he
who remains kang looking around this room here and
just where this exists in space time also feels
very similar to that scene from the loki finale
loki and sylvie meeting he who remains at his
citadel at the end of time like everything
looks really ancient in this room of his like it
looks like strange supremes sanctum not our doctor
strange's sanctum it outside the window here it
looks like reality is about to end and like i said
the way marvel plays this trailer reveal with bear
mordo's voice over they really want us to think at
least at first glance the doctor strange supreme
is the real main villain of the movie that could
be a misdirect like all the spider-man no way home
trailers were very misleading about tobey maguire
and andrew garfield in the movie but whatever
the main threat to reality is like reality itself
breaking down this seems like the event horizon
outside like this giant maelstrom with a really
bright white light at the center but this is
really just scratching the surface there's so much
stuff going on in this movie we have what looks
like concept art of patrick stewart's professor
x or a version of him from the multiverse
there's supposedly going to be some version of
the illuminati there's even a version of him here
looking like he's controlling some ultron robots
bringing doctor strange in to talk to him and his
special chair looks like the gold one that he used
during x-men the animated series there's also been
merch that they've revealed for a bunch of other
cameo characters like despair sleepwalker rintrah
the minotaur those were all other really powerful
magic users there was even some concept art for a
version of clea so clia might also show up in the
movie at some point but if you spotted any other
easter eggs in this trailer that i didn't talk
about during the video just write them below in
the comments if you have any big questions about
what's going on in the movie they'll probably
release a version of this trailer publicly or
a slightly different version of it in the next
couple of weeks of course i'll be doing all kinds
of videos for this just like i did for spider-man
no way home so no worries there's a bunch of other
spider-man videos that i'm working on too so make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss that congratulations baked yoda
you're the giveaway winner for my last big
spider-man video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for that other spider-man no
way home post credit scene video and click here
for my full spider-man no way home easter eggs
video for the entire movie the ending everything
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!